Hanscom Prez my name is anyway welcome
to three free games with parents we're
gonna start off I'm playing run Jesus
run run Jesus run it you start off as a
little pixel fate of Jesus here and we
can run at how do we play let me try
this there you go it's go Jesus all
right
and Jesus go now [ __ ] sake Jesus
typical Jesus to get crucified hey wise
men how you doing oh [ __ ] go Jesus go go
Jesus go Jesus Jesus Jesus Jesus
yes oh god what is happening how many
Passos five [ __ ] did I fail what is this
game here we go what now what now what
now
oh [ __ ] sake oh did I miss this is the
greatest game I don't notice that way I
haven't played this game with my entire
channel oh my god are you telling me I
didn't have to hold down oh oh there's a
timer okay okay I got it
oh [ __ ] sake
please give me 12 what one more let's
play those damn knit bells study the
flashing it both now aim for where the
nipples would have moved into the next
boob
oh my [ __ ] god
nuts boob air bed
great oh now I understand the tits
change and I need to adapt to the
boobies it all makes sense
boots do not work that way [ __ ] please
damn it
why is nipple placement so hard Jesus
why did you make it so weird
come on nipples
come on that bus last game bros so many
of you have suggested this game it's the
attack on titan tribute game i'll be the
potato girl who's the potato girl again
she's my favorite
Sasha yes I can be potato girl oh man
all right here we are
oh Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] is
happening oh my god it's just sexy Oh
Micah so kawaii so kawaii
oh god he's so sexy I would never hurt
him
okay let's kill him whoa get rekt yes
yes
Cody's [ __ ] AI xiaofang Carter's
[ __ ] arse over oh God oh my limbs Oh
No potato girl my tater no big deal I
can just respond all right
okay there's so many Titans that's a
level three Sugoi desu urchin charted
okay let's try
perfect time he's trying to have a snack
[ __ ] you and your snacks [ __ ]
Oh get rekt you're gonna die bad oh you
mad at my fabric alright for us that
will be any girl has blessed us with yet
another eyeliner game skeletal dance
simulator 2019 yeah oh my god this is my
game this is my jam this is my jam
I am literally stuffing my face with jam
right now Sep skill is skilled I'm gonna
kill you wake up o [ __ ] oh oh
[ __ ] up [ __ ] oh no he's killing me it's
killing me then I guess it's dead now we
can animate it go skill excu dance
you're the greatest dancer in the place
this is this is so an emu I can't even
[ __ ] a row yeah the dancing they dancing
oh oh thank Izzie [ __ ] him up Skelly's
[ __ ] him up good they need to be dipped
in the blood of their motto Ernest
sponsor eagle has blessed us with yet
another game go home you're drunk oh
yeah
alright I'll call my monkey God that was
all right we got this trashcan of it
what
all right trashcan no [ __ ] sake box this
is impossible
Barker what parkour that was the sickest
part of code I've seen him I left I hate
this game
he's worse than flappy bird
why do I compose your composure or sure
oh my god
five six oh [ __ ] today all right that
was a good time to end this episode
thank you sponsor we go thank you for
blessing me with our games and thank you
for liking this video or sponsor Eagle
will eat your face when you sleep
alright thank you for watching I always
appreciate it not a lot of fun today and
I will see you in the next video stay
awesome press oh my god how do you do
that with a nose I could never do that
my nose is too wide I can't do it